l'avocate de maurice papon saisissez
hier la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme pour protester contre le
maintien en détention de son client
qu'il juge contraire au droit européen
et aujourd'hui robert badinter sur la
chaîne parlementaire public sénat
jugeait que ce maintien en prison de
maurice papon n'avait plus de portée
l'oeuvre de la justice la mise en
lumière si importante pour les jeunes
générations de ce qui était advenu et la
condamnation intervenue
cela satisfait à mes yeux
l'exigence de justice c'est un vieillard
le maintenir en prison
à 7h là là à mes yeux plus de portée et
u
vous voyez on dit crimes contre
l'humanité et je dirais il ya un moment
où l'unité doit prévaloir sur le crime